auch das reisechaos jeder soll in einer
ersten provinz absolut das wird nämlich
immer schlimmer jetzt verschwinden sogar
flüge von der bildfläche so geschehen
mit dem lufthansa flug lh
202 die maschine sollte am samstag um 21
uhr 15 von frankfurt nach berlin fliegen
doch auf der anzeigetafel tauchte die
maschine nicht auf per e mail erhielten
die fluggäste dann nur die änderung des
gates allerdings weiter dieses drama am
flugsteig dann die lautsprecherdurchsage
flug ersatzlos gestrichen und auch für
den nächsten tag gibt es kein ausweich
flugpassagiere sollten die bahn nehmen
hotels gebe es auch nicht alles voll
hieß es ja mit fliegen wollten
eigentlich ex bild chef kai diekmann und
tv kommentator frank buschmann diekmann
begleitete das chaos auf twitter und
dann plötzlich man kann es sich wirklich
nicht ausdenken schreibt er da ganz
richtig lufthansa antwortet auf seinen
tweet hague will uns leid das ist ja
schon ganz nett aber dann ja wir wissen
selber nicht so richtig wie sie selbst
ratlos und wissen nicht wo flug 202
eigentlich ist er ja inzwischen
annulliert wurde wie bitte moment ein
bisschen einmal kurz fragen lufthansa
weiß nicht wo der eigene flug ist eine
irre geschichte die noch immer kommt
denn anscheinend ging dieser flug am
ende doch nach berlin noch mit etwas
verspätung und ohne diekmann und ohne
buschmann die dass beide natürlich nicht
besonders witzig finden sie hier der tv
kommentator frank buschmann stieg
nämlich am ende auf die bahn um und das
hat gedauert stadt nach wie geplant an
eine stunde und zehn minuten in berlin
zu landen kam er dann erst nach mehreren
stunden im morgengrauen in der
hauptstadt an da ist die bahn dann doch
ein bisschen langsamer als das flugzeug
übrigens auch gestern ging die lh 202
nicht nachreisen
2022 ein echter traum absolut auffallen
wenn man dann diese will denn hier sieht
flugchaos ist das eine aber dann auch
noch das koffer chaos am flughafen
frankfurt gepäck wo man nur hinlegt
alles koffer von passagieren deren flüge
annulliert wurden transitreisende die
trifft das einem besonders schlimmen
normalerweise wird ja ihr koffer zum
nächsten flug gebracht der aber aus dann
sollte man seinen koffer in dieser menge
irgendwo selbst finden herzlichen
glückwunsch das kann stunden dauern tja
das chaos an den flughäfen
wie bekommen wir das eigentlich in den
griffen wer trägt die verantwortung
unser kollege teilweise verkehrsminister
volker wissing in einem die richtigen
fragen spezial gefragt wer verantwortet
das flug-chaos in deutschland die
fluggesellschaften die
flughafenbetreiber dann die fluggäste
bezahlen ja für die leistungen und
deswegen den orcas und vorkasse deswegen
haben sie den anspruch darauf dass die
leistung erbracht wird das funktioniert
jetzt nicht weil personal bei den
unternehmen fehlt und deswegen müssen
die unternehmen diese personalprobleme
lösen ganz offensichtlich hat man in
ganz europa das problem dass die
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter während
der pandemie sich neue beschäftigungen
gesucht haben und jetzt nicht mehr zur
verfügung stehen um koffer zu verladen
um sicherheits kontrollen durchzuführen
und vieles mehr aber wir müssen auch
klar sehen es war von anfang an nicht zu
erwarten dass nach diesem lockdown bei
einer wiederöffnung
alles sofort wieder so ist wie es vorher
war und darauf muss die gesellschaftlich
einstellen und jetzt müssen wir nun
müssen wir schauen was können wir tun
damit wir
arbeitskräfte zuwanderung aus dem
ausland so einfach wie möglich machen
wir brauchen auch ein besseres
zuwanderungsrecht in deutschland das
fachkräfteproblem ist in der mitte der
gesellschaft angekommen es
beeinträchtigt unseren alltag es ist
nicht nur mehr ein theoretisches problem
ist ein kurioser worden würden sie
gepäckabfertigung machen
ich finde und das wäre das was wir sagen
würden das ist ein ehrenwerter und ein
wichtiger beruf in unserer gesellschaft
und wir müssen uns aber das ist eine
verantwortung die wir alle haben die
frage stellen werden diese leute
angemessen bezahlt sind diese berufe
ausreichend attraktiv und was können wir
tun um die attraktiver zu gestalten ja
so also volker wissing unser
bundesverkehrsminister heute morgen hier
bei uns im studio